[Music]
commander hawthorne you know how i feel
about rookies the same way i feel about
autopilots how may i assist you is there
anything i can do sir they don't help
they just over complicate things i'm
better off just doing the job myself
which is why i brought the rookie
uh hello
no buzz protocol requires we bring him
along he's going to have sad eyes buzz
you know i can't deal with saturday it's
the rookie buzz nope look at the r
oh no you look at him looking look nope
no no no no no no the rookie
all right all right you win
look feather feathering's feather it's a
feather an imp sir look rookie first you
will not speak unless spoken to yes sir
still talking second respect the suit
this suit means something it's not just
protecting your body it's protecting the
universe this suit is a promise to the
world that you and you alone will do one
thing above all finish the mission no
matter the cost you will never quit
whatever the galaxy may throw your way
will you please turn that off
it's just suicide you're mocking me
aren't you yeah but in a supportive way
[Music]
i am socks your personal companion robot
my what i was issued by star command to
ease your emotional transition after
your time away oh well that's very
considerate of you robot feline but no
thank you i'm afraid it's protocol
censors indicate you've missed four
birthdays would you like a frosted snack
cake to celebrate negative that would
compromise my nutritional regimen
we can talk about your feelings i am an
excellent listener no no look i've had a
very long
day
it did not go as planned the mission was
unsuccessful
affirmative oh no i am so sorry to hear
that
thank you sucks
you're welcome buzz
shall we play a game no thank you are
you sure i can create a game
specifically for you based on your exact
personality profile hey listen socks
buddy i'm pretty tired so i'm gonna go
ahead and hit the rack of course
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well goodnight socks good
night buzz
stop right now put your hands over your
head
[Music]
all
right the silo doors he isn't going
anywhere
unauthorized
just come on we're sitting ducks here
allow me
[Music]
wait what's happening he overrode my
override
[Music]
let's break this hyper speed barrier get
everyone home
let's review our objectives kill the
robots and don't die
don't die it's just something you want
to do every day it's still an objective
if i may we have one objective we need
to put this crystal in the turnip and
get out of here so to do that we have to
get onto the base to do that we have to
kill all the robots to do that we have
to destroy the zerg ship and to do any
of that we have to not die
um derek allow me to explain operation
surprise party it is a variation on
operation thunder spear didn't you get a
medal for that one two actually but uh
wait how do you know about operation
thundersphere i've read all my grandma's
space ranger books from cover to cover
twice
excuse me robot kitty cat sorry
sensors have indicated that dessert [ __ ]
powers the robots on the ground so we
fly up there we blow up the ship and
surprise robots you're toast then we put
your crystal in the tournament and
finish the mission
it's a good plan
to infinity
are you trying to get me to pull your
finger don't fall for it no not like
that it was
sorry it's a thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
i we would never she didn't mean to
anyway forget it
buzz lightyear mission log from the
studio that brought you toy story
um socks you're inhibiting my visual oh
sorry is this better negative okay how
about this
on june 17. all right space rangers
let's do this here we go
available now
i've been a fan of buzz
since the first time that i saw toy
story to infinity and beyond it's one of
my favorite movies
the movie toy story was such an
impactful film thank you all thank you
it's so iconic and the characters had
such variety
they just offer something that's so
relatable
for over 20 years i've been percolating
on this idea of
what is the world buzz lightyear comes
from
this film is the origin story of buzz
lightyear
finally it's the story that made andy
and his friends want to go buy a buzz
like your toy
having the opportunity to take your
childhood hero and make a fictional
movie about them
that was just a really fun challenge
was like your mission log
there seems to be no sign of intelligent
life anywhere who are you talking to uh
no one
you were narrating again i was not yeah
that's great
[Music]
the kind of person that you want to lead
you on an adventure
he's obsessed with being the hero are we
going to crash
sometimes to a fault this is my mistake
i need to make it right fuzz meets a
team of specialists
don't worry we got you
did i
this is exciting a new adventure sox is
the cutest member of the team
just hang on
lightyear raises the bar
an intergalactic experience
go
all right space rangers ready ready
ready no wait not really
i'm a massive fixer fan i was a kid in a
candy store watch out it's unlike any
pixar movie to date
i will never forget the first time i got
to say to infinity
and beyond well this is pretty cool omg
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking about uh no one
you were narrating again i was not just
doing the mission log you do know no one
ever listens to that i know that
narrating helps me focus
ready captain light you ready as i'll
ever be commander hawthorne this is
exciting a new adventure i'm gonna grant
you four minutes to be off planet but
then you come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyperlaunch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
buzz lightyear star command come in star
command
why don't they answer
hey
the what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long were we gone yum yum yum
yum yum
years seven months and five days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was gonna be like a
fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
anyone saying the harpoons
[Music]
right here
[Music]
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2
seems a bit low mission failure imminent
in three grandma always said she
believed in you too
there was a big swelling too i think i
need a bed at least record your last
words do not vomit inside the vehicle
if you are satisfied with this recording
speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
[Music]
bye